all right if you ever wanted to be a fly
on the wall in the Cabinet Room of the
White House you just got an opportunity
to listen in on a conversation the
president was happening with a couple of
Governors and of course the Secretary of
Interior Dave Bernhardt taking a lot of
questions from the press as well so we
still have the five together so we'll
take it around the table so to speak
Jessie maybe let's just start on the
bigger news today on the Flynn unmasking
list that has come out the president
talking about that he has an interview
with Maria Bartiromo which will air
tomorrow morning
he says there's more to come well there
keeps being more to come and he's been
right and Fox has been right all of our
reporting on this entire thing has
proven to be accurate and all of the
reporting from the other side and the
mainstream media has proven false which
makes me wonder why aren't the
mainstream media reporters angry they
were fed lies by their sources for three
years and they printed fake news now if
I printed fake news for three years and
then I found out through the transcripts
that my sources knew they were telling
me lies and knew they were having me
push a fake story I'd be angry at my
sources but they're not angry at their
sources they're angry at the people that
have pointed out that their sources lied
think about how ridiculous that is now
they're saying the president is
politicizing the intelligence that's
pretty funny coming from them because it
wasn't Donald Trump that set people up
with stings that used spies that cooked
up crooked dossiers included with the
Russians and entrap people and through
political opponents in jail no that was
the Democrats that did that all the
president is doing now like this
unmasking list is shining a light all
he's doing is disinfecting the last
administration he's exposing it he's
correcting an injustice that's what's
going on here and the timing is not
being used to distract from the pandemic
it was Adam Schiff that released all of
those transcripts under oath remember
that and it was the Justice Department
the
held the exculpatory evidence from
general Flint for two years so the
timing of all of this it's on the
Democrats it's not on the Republicans
Greg Jesse brings up something that
reminds me of do you remember during the
Obama administration when Ben Rhodes the
national security communications guy
said did that whole interview basically
saying that he had played the media on
Iran how they had just fell for
everything that he said I mean one of
the jet just said that it made me think
about how reporters I mean you would
have think they would have been mad then
yet I feel like a broken record but the
fact is look I just I I just saw I think
it was one of Biden's spokesperson
meltdown on Twitter over this basically
attacked Catherine Herridge pretty
brutal attack on her and I believe they
might have removed the tweet I'm just
interested how the media is gonna
approach that will that be considered a
sexist attack because she's a woman
or is it different because it was a
Democrat doing the attacking but it's
clear that Joe's campaign is worried and
I hate yeah I hate to protect I hate to
act like the worse the very worst of the
media the very worst of the Democrats
about demanding this person get locked
up and this person be tried and this
person go away but something's got to be
done for Adam Schiff because he he
created three years of a massive fallacy
that did so much damage to this country
and and and made us miss probably one of
the most important stories of our
lifetime we we were having hearings on
impeachment while the corona virus was
exploding we talked about that virus in
green rooms but we were we had to do
this impeachment story we had to show
these hearings it's all on him man he's
got to go they got to investigate him
they got to hold him accountable I'm not
gonna say he should go to prison but my
evil twin will say he should go away to
prison for a very long time
one I think that the next few days are
going to be very interesting to see how
many Democrats are going to be willing
to talk on the record
about what's been going on and what's
been revealed well I think people are
glad to talk I think the question is are
you playing into a political action you
know you know regardless of how you view
it I think lots of people do worry that
it is diversionary certainly Vice
President Biden has said that the other
thing that I wanted to mention to you
Dana was I think the president was
pretty clear he said that the Democrats
bill that Nancy Pelosi put out today is
do a dead on arrival and then he said
that Jay Powell the Federal Reserve
chair is his most improved player over
the last few months for reducing
interest rates and the like but today
Jay Powell came out and said you know
the economy is in big trouble and needs
additional help and support from the
government so the question now becomes
what will the president and the Treasury
secretary mr. manukan put forward are
they going to negotiate because their
own Federal Reserve chair the most
improved player for the president is
saying the economy the workers need help
and Nancy Pelosi is talking about
getting more money to workers more money
for kids who are hungry through food
stamps more money for small business
well and also having the government play
God on a lot of things which perhaps is
not the best way to get money in the
hands of people to do stuff but well
hopefully we're going to talk about that
today hopefully we'll get a chance
tomorrow Emily could I talk to you a
little bit about this reopening he's
talking to the governors are you seeing
that out in where you are that the parks
are reopening that people are figuring
out a way to get back to business you
meant as you mentioned that there's a
possible registry at restaurants in
Seattle exactly that the governor has
outlined a plan for a restaurant to be
able to have dine in people so for
people to be able to go and sit in door
they have to provide the restaurants
have to stipulate agree to a stipulation
they'll provide the names email
addresses and telephone numbers of those
diners so of course people are sort of
revolting it remains to be seen
obviously whether that's going to be
implemented but as of now the governor
has articulated that if I may Dana you
asked before we cut to the president
about California which is where I'm from
and we saw the difference of the
governor's treatment in California of
all of those other governor's that were
in the Cabinet Room with the president
governor Newsom is operating under a
short term crisis psychology and it's in
stark contrast to that long term
fundamental unraveling that we are
watching there Emily will pick it back
up tomorrow